back in the early 20th century the
discovery of antibiotics revolutionized
medicine before that people regularly
died of minor infections like toothaches
antibiotics have become among the most
commonly prescribed drugs in the world
but many no longer work the problem is
bacteria are evolving to resist them
superbugs thrive when doctors
overprescribe or when patients don't
finish their prescribed dose it's a
problem in livestock to seventy percent
of antibiotics sold in the US are fed to
livestock why to give animals immunity
to disease in unsanitary holding pens
and to artificially fatten them up while
it might be good short-term business for
farms and pharma their use is helping
superbugs thrive and just as we've got
more bugs we've got fewer drugs
pharmaceutical companies are
discontinuing their research into new
antibiotics simply because they can't
turn a profit if superbugs outsmart
modern medicine are you ready to die
over a toothache
you